hello and Martine Burt I come from
Paraguay and I would like to answer the
question posed by lees any from what a
turbot resile my neighbor the question
is how do you intend to improve the
education of people with respect to the
environment I think that we have to
change three things first we have to
change the curriculum today in many
countries of the world that curriculum
does not incorporate environmental
issues the second thing that we have to
do is that we have to improve the
pedagogy how the teaching is done so
that students can relate to the
environment and the students can read
see how their personal actions affect
the environment and third we have to
incur change the way we evaluate schools
with regard to environment it's not if
the student does well and a test but how
the school grounds are clean where the
trash and the garbage produced by the
student and the students were US gold so
I think that educational system has to
affect the environment we are working in
Paraguay at the maracas jus forest
reserve teaching Paraguay on Brazilian
and native Indian students how to make
money from the forest without cutting
any trees by tourism by botany by
working with a standing forest and we
would very much love to work with a
friendship positions hello thank you
very much yours